18 25 par deux ça fait 36 50 monsieur
s'est multipliée par 2 1 ah si je vous
dis regardez ça fait 10 825 vous êtes
touristes les vacanciers les prix
multiplié par deux les étrangers par
trois repas vous n'êtes pas étranger non
maintenant si simplement par deux donc
de 18 25 on passe à 36 50 on assomme les
touristes et les étrangers maintenant on
le dit c'est nouveau ce nouveau qu'on le
dise ah oui mais maintenant moi j'ai
décidé de le dire parce qu on le fait et
sans le dire je trouve pas ça aux nets
signés d'être honnête avec les gens
qu'on a sous la main
c'est vrai qu'on les vols ou au moins
leur dis maintenant c'est plus régulier
ou pensez pas fait ça tout le temps
madame tout le temps c'est depuis les
pics la côte d'azur du succès on vous
vole on a trois mois pour vous voulez
c'est pas évident parce que là l'hiver
vous venez pas vous ici on n'a que trois
mois pour vous voler encore le mois de
juin est pas facile hein
donc on a vraiment juillet août pour
vous tirer le maximum de pognon coin des
convois des blaireaux comme vous hop on
les presse comme des citrons coin c'est
marrant non
les 340 de fond monsieur 114 x 3 est ce
que vous êtes touristes
j'ai de quoi vous êtes suisse allemand
les prix vont regarder monsieur les prix
sont multipliés par deux pour les
vacanciers parfois pour les étrangers
pourquoi ce qu'on est en saison on
assène de touristes ici monsieur on a
trois mois pour faire de l'argent
vous le savez bien tout le monde le sait
on le marque donc ça fait 340 de francs
vous allez bien vous êtes volet sur la
côte d'azur monsieur vous le savez bien
monsieur bonjour thomas marie vous
mettez le doigt bien profond et vous
sentez après les voies et vannes de
maraîchers quoi affligeant ici on pèse
ici on assomme passerait 90
nike et si oui ça fait trente francs
suisses et allemands s'est multiplié par
trois pour les prix donnent un regard d
c'est du vol
c'est de l'intubation les en cubes
les en tube les étrangers on fait comme
ça en cubes et entuber de fait le tweet
tweet la classe en tube on le remet dans
le cucquois là ok voilà on va lancer la
traîne pas savonner watts
non non non aïe stole you you monnaie
ouais
because it's côte d'azur et sur you à
bhl héros blaireau me said les touristes
au match au monopole aux mods on vous a
gagné et on vous remercie
bien sûr si les prix ou socialement
c'était trois fois le prix non 134
monsieur bah s'emballe et vous vous êtes
arrivé quand
on vous a également tué c'est pas du
tout moins cher